many of you may be wondering how to help
people in ukraine and refugees from
other countries as well one surprising
effort using airbnbs to send money
directly to the people in ukraine airbnb
says more than 61 thousand nights were
booked in ukraine on march 2nd and 3rd
now airbnb is not taking fees from that
so they're not making money off the
bookings cbs news business analyst joe
schlesinger joins us right now good
morning i want to i want to talk about
that in a second but let's talk about
the stocks they tumbled and they took a
sharp drop off yeah it was a bad day
really bad day oil went to 100 20 a
barrel this is really concerning to many
investors they think people are going to
stop spending money broadly in the
economy could cause a recession really
bad day worst day for the s p 500 this
year s p and the dow are now both in
correction down more than 10
and the nasdaq's actually in a bear
market down more than 20 down 21 but
look you got a portfolio you got a game
plan stick to it let's not take any new
actions try to just take a deep breath
don't panic because what you're saying
indeed okay i love hearing that from you
um now what about some other grassroot
efforts um where people can give because
that's what that's what's on our heart
right now absolutely you know the airbnb
effort so interesting started online
really was like almost like
crowdsourcing great idea we also see
that uber did something really
interesting uber has basically said
we're going to give free rides to people
who are at the ukrainian polish border
and we're going to give those rides to
folks who want to go deeper into poland
they're helping relief workers there as
well so free rides through uber and uber
users here in the us can give through
the app etsy said no fees for people who
are selling stuff who are based in the
ukraine a lot of people on etsy actually
buying some items from folks in ukraine
to help them out i heard something about
the vice prime minister of ukraine
encouraging people to give in crypto i
hear crypto i think you could be scammed
yes it's really interesting because he
put a tweet out and they got a lot of
response a hundred thousand donations
more than uh 54
million dollars that was raised very
quickly this is great if someone who's
owned crypto for a long time and knows
what they're doing right and if you've
got embedded gains but you're right
scams do exist it's unfortunate when
stuff like this happens scammers come
out right absolutely the ftc just sent
out a warning as a matter of fact they
said if you've got an organization make
sure it's legit you can just actually
google do a search and say the name of
the organization plus scam and then you
can see a little bit more information
from maybe charity navigator or the
better business bureau wise giving
alliance thank you for letting us know
the deal jill thank you